hey guys now you know that I always say
at the end of my videos that life is
short so don't waste yours right and
it's personal to me because you already
know I lost two brothers
so I want to use every second that I
have for the right reasons and it is
important for me to share that with you
guys so today is a big day because we
have finally started our merch shop the
merch shop of men's Lifestyle the first
design is life is short don't waste
yours we got it in this design as well
there you go
expect to see some more designs coming
out soon and you can get it on different
products support us please because the
income that I get from this it doesn't
come to me at all it goes directly to
the editors
and they work really hard behind the
scenes thank you for all the support I
love you guys I'll see you in the next
video and always remember life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys